اد مرسل الجزيره بان مسيره اسرائيليه
استهدفت سياره قائد ميداني بارس في حزب
الله ببلده خربه سلم جنوبيه لبنان ما ادى
لمقتله واصابه اخر كان
برفقته معنا من ارميش جنوبيه لبنان مدير
مكتب الجزيره مازن ابراهيم وتنضم الينا من
الجليل الاعلى مراسله الجزيره فاطمه
خمايسي ونبدا باخر التطورات معك مازن لاسم
ما اعلن عن استهداف قائد ميداني وقتله من
مقاتل حزب
الله في الواقع قبل قليل اعلن حزب الله عن
استشهاد القائد الميداني وسام طويل والذي
استشهد في هذه الغاره الاسرائيليه التي
استهدفت سياره في بلده خربه سلم قبل نحو
ساعتين من الان من خلال عمليه وصفت هنا
على نطاق واسع بانها عمليه اغتيال من قبل
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وانها نفذت هذه
العمليه من خلال اطلاق صواريخ موجهه على
السياره التي كان
يستقلها هذا القائد الميداني يعتبر قائدا
بارزا على المستوى التنظيمي في في حزب
الله وتحديدا على المستوى العسكري المباشر
المعطيات الاوليه تشير الى انه ينتمي الى
وحده الرضوان وهو لديه مهام عسكريه
وميدانيه واسعه هنا في جنوب لبنان وان كان
يصنف ضمن الدرجه الثانيه من القيادات
الميدانيه ضمن هذه الوحده التي تنتشر على
كامل الاراضي الجنوبيه وتحديدا الحدود
الجنوبيه للبنان عمليا يمكن اعتبار بان ما
حصل اليوم وفق التوصيف الذي يعتمده حزب
الله الان بانها عمليه اغتيال مباشره
لقائد بارز هنا لابد من الاشاره ايضا بان
هذا القائد المستوى التنظيمي الذي يصله
والذي يحتله هو الاعلى رتبه بين كل شهداء
حزب الله الذين سقطوا في هذه المواجهات
منذ الثامن من اكتوبر هنا دعني احيلك الى
عمليه مشابهه حصلت في الان من شهر نوفمبر
وحينها استشهد خمسه من كبار القاض
الميدانيين لحزب الله من ضمنهم النجل رئيس
كتلتها النيابيه محمد رعد هذا القائد الذي
استشهد اليوم هو في رتبه ميدانيه اعلى من
كل هؤلاء وبالتالي حزب الله يتعامل اليوم
مع هذا الاغتيال بوصفه رساله اضافيه ضاف
الى كل الرسائل التي وصلت من قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والتي شهدنا هذا
النسق المتصاعد في عمليات الاغتيال سواء
مما بدا في دمشق من خ من خلال اغتيال
واستهداف راضي الموسوي وهو القائد
والمستشار في الحرس الثوري الايراني اعقب
ذلك الاستهداف المباشر وعمليه الاغتيال
للشهيد صالح العاروري ورفاق في قلب ضاحيه
بيروت الجنوبيه واليوم ياتي هذا الاستهداف
بشكل مباشر صحيح ان هنالك فروقات بطبيعه
المستوى القيادي لكل من هؤلاء الذين
ذكرتهم ولكن من الواضح ان هذا النسق الذي
تعتمده قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بات يؤشر
الى رغبه متزايده في جر الامور الى مربع
مختلف وهذا ما كان قد تحدث عنه رئيس حكومه
تصيف الاعمال نجيب مقاطي عندما قال بان
اسرائيل من خلال هذه الاستهدافات تسعى الى
نقل لبنان الى مربع مختلف وبالتالي اليوم
عندما نفذ حزب الله بالامس هذا الاستهداف
للقاعده العسكريه
الاسرائيليه قاعده ميرون ردا كرد اولي على
اغتيال صالح العاروري يجد نفسه اليوم امام
استهداف اضافي جديد وبالتالي لائحه الردود
باتت تطول وهنالك من يرى بان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يسعى من خلال كل هذه العمليات
التي باتت متسارعه على مستويين على مستوى
الاغتيالات من جهه وعلى مستوى ثان يتعلق
بطبيعه الاستهدافات التي نراها من خلال
الطائرات الحربيه المقاتله والمسيرات
والقصف المدفعي الذي بات يستهدف مجموعه
كبيره من البلدات الجنوبيه ونحن لم نعد
نتحدث زين العابدين عن بلدات حدوديه
ولكننا نتحدث عن عمق جنوب لبنان قبل ايام
كان هنالك غاره وصلت الى بلده كوثر السياد
ونتحدث هنا عن قضاء صيدا صحيح انها تبعد
اكثر من 20 را عن مدينه صيدا وهي مركز هذا
القضاء ولكن وصول الغارات الى تلك النقطه
اعتبر ايضا كمتغير كبير على مستوى
الاستهدافات وعمق هذه الاستهدافات من هنا
بدنا نتحدث خلال الايام والاسبوعين
الماضيين تحديدا عن نسق من العمليات
العسكريه التي تنفذها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على كامل في كامل جنوب لبنان
بانها باتت اكثر عنفا اكثر شده وان
الاسلحه التي تستخدم سواء من خلال
المقاطعات الحربيه والصواريخ التي تطلق
وايضا يجري الحديث عن صواريخ موجهه باتت
تستهدف البلدات كما حصل صباح اليوم من
خلال اطلاق مجموعه كبيره من البلدات اخرها
كان استهداف بغارات جويه لبلده عيتا الشعب
التي تشاهدها في الخلفيه كل هذه المعطيات
تتقاطع على ان الامور هنا باتت في وضع
متازم جدا